a man has two women
one he's honest with and one he lies to
which one does he love
what he lies to yeah yeah
the one he lies
oh it's interesting which one is because
he's more attracted to the one that's
honest with her the one that lies to her
the one that lies you think 100 I feel
like girls kind of like [ __ ] you
know so like the guys
that's what I mean so like if a girl has
two guys and one's brutally honest and
one lies to her oh like I thought you
meant honest like just honest and open
and sort of like you know what I mean no
I mean I've been like brutally honest
like dude so what like guys have two
girls one he's brutally honest with one
he lies to which one does he loved yeah
the one because just in that scenario
I'm not they're not gonna catch me
slipping here I'm gonna make sure I've
got my exactly
what I'm trying to say is the issue is
that he's got two women
that's the issue from where you start
there then you got to whoever you're
lying to is who you care about the most
yeah but that's I mean that's how modern
relationship starts though when it comes
for a sex or relationship
usually
you said what comes first like in in
Modern Times And so you basically you're
starting off as a side chick because the
guys the guys the girls want aren't like
they're usually sleeping with more than
one girl
and you might get promoted to me and
people you might still cheat we'll see
in the beginning this is how
relationships start and it might maybe
both ways maybe yeah but you should have
said like in the beginning he's brutally
honest with one and he lies to the other
yeah
in those in those situations because
women I would argue that women are more
attracted to the guy that's brutally
honest with her but it's funny because
it's like the opposite I don't I don't
think so wait
no I see actually I can't talk too much
about this
no you know what go ahead yeah I think I
think I think both sides I think
worse okay when I hear lighter I'm like
lying to make her hear what she wants or
if I can keep her happy and then the
britally honest part I think
they do find more attractive when
Communications were like breaking down
and it's like no this is what's gonna
happen I mean if I like to say we're
getting put in a place or some [ __ ] but
they like having an argument they like
you know tension and all that [ __ ] but
if you're angry and the guys like just
happy like oh hi hi yeah would actually
just lying to other Rosie then she's
probably just gonna duck
it's interesting because it's almost
like the opposite like women want like
that's almost like the problem in a way
because like the one that he lies to is
the one that he loves the most but the
one that she loves the most is the one
that's brutally honest and doesn't
really care as much about her feelings
no no not why Skyler did what she did in
pretty bad it makes sense
I thought that show in 2013 I'm still in
season three
it's just not for me man that's a new
problem
it's 8 48 yeah I think it's time to wrap
it up I was gonna say Story Time myself
do we have the time
but we try and then
story
oh yeah I do what do you think Jess
which story should I tell you have so
many
um no
um you already told the whale one
um so I told you one from today or a
different one
I mean you can combine that with the
other incident that you had the first
incident and then combined with that one
well the first incident the body count
one and you can come back
yeah so sometimes girls come on my
podcast and they see some wild stuff
yeah and I I feel like as a grown adult
like if you you came on my podcast you
came on my podcast and if you chose to
say a story that you didn't want out
there what how is that my problem yeah
like how is that my fault you grown
adults so I've had this problem where
girls will come on they'll say wild
stuff and then they'll regret it later
and then ask me to take the stream down
I think that's very selfish and entitled
to you because I feel extreme yeah they
want me to take it all down because I
paid my producer I paid Jess I pay like
I pay all these people like it cost me
probably maybe a grand to do a show so
it's like you're asking me to take all
this down and so I had one girl that
decided to say her body count I actually
had two girls that both decided to say
their body counts online yeah what were
they
one was 30 something 40 something and
one was five okay and so both in both
situations I I said it as a joke well
when the first situation I said it as a
joke so I was like what's your guys's
body count and then she's like I want to
say it and I said are you sure
she says yes you you you you you went
out no one else in the room said she
gave closer on screen as well oh that's
crazy and then this girl tends to sue me
threatens to yeah and this other girl
she didn't say body count this other
girl threatened to come beat me up with
her brothers and at this and this recent
one is threatening to kill me but
her body count was five allegedly right
that's what she said but she's like in a
Muslim Community oh
so it's like like I was like the men in
the west would pray for five but
yeah but she's threatening to kill me
allegedly like yeah she's gonna send
some someone from the Muslim Community
to kill me
yeah
when they came to you and obviously he
told you to take down the stream and you
told them ignore them
you don't deserve my energy did they
what was like were they just constantly
yeah they just get mad or they're like
[Music]
because it's like so entitled you want
me to do it for nothing you want me to
do it for zero dollars and I spent all
this money on a stream you agreed to
come on you and a lot of times it's
funny because they'll go out of their
way they make the whole conversation
about them they'll dominate everything
and that's not my fault and then we ask
questions like that's not my fault and
yeah this recent one is fattening to
kill me but I told her I was like you
have three options with me you can
either kill me then I don't have to
worry about it you can come beat me up
but I swear to God I will get everything
on camera I have cameras everywhere here
you will not you will not catch me
slipping make money off of this
I swear to God you you can go sue me
good luck I have your consent on camera
I record when everyone comes into the
podcast I have that backed up on a ring
good luck I have you signed consent for
okay good luck so sue me try to kill me
then I'll be dead so I won't worry about
it and the stream will still be up so
yeah that's fine
that's that's my that's my story is that
a lot of girls get mad and I get death
threats I get but I just feel like do it
wow do it yeah you will not you will not
bully me you will not I will not be
bullied on my own show
the thing is is Peak when you give them
consent on camera as well
with stuff like that you just got out of
schools
[Music]
okay foreign
here she said five but in the Muslim
Community I guess she's a [ __ ] it was
like Haram yeah but again she knows that
coming yeah
she's blaming you yeah yeah like like
apparently it's my fault and it's funny
it's only women that do this like I've
never had a I've had guys get get
roasted like whatever oh someone made a
whole video about the episode of me and
Tom and came on we made a whole video
that and he was like insulting us and
[ __ ] it was like I was like all right
wow yeah
that's just you know what I mean that
happens but I don't I can't control what
you say on a podcast so I'm like but
this girl I said you can kill me then
because I will not I will not be bullied
you didn't call us uh she wasn't under
any influence she signed she jumped on
camera she said you are a YouTuber
something if if she has an issue with
you
wait maybe we can get an on the card of
a Jake Paul fight yeah you can set it up
you versus her don't do that yeah
no I told her I gave her a price that I
would take it down for her but it was
very it's gonna be expensive yeah
like it's like thousands because you
were asking me to give up on thousands
of dollars and I make off of these clips
that you know what I'm saying like so
like how entitled are you the girls that
is so entitled
so as many of you know I was just banned
on Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible